So once again, we
have three equal,
or we say three
identical objects.
They all have the
same mass, but we
don't know what the
mass is of each of them.
But what we do know is that
if you total up their mass,
it's the same exact mass
as these nine objects
right over here.
And each of these nine objects
have a mass of 1 kilograms.
So in total, you have 9
kilograms on this side.
And over here, you
have three objects.
They all have the same mass.
And we don't know what it is.
We're just calling that mass x.
And what I want
to do here is try
to tackle this a little
bit more symbolically.
In the last video, we
said, hey, why don't we
just multiply 1/3 of this
and multiply 1/3 of this?
And then, essentially,
we're going
to keep things
balanced, because we're
taking 1/3 of the same mass.
This total is the
same as this total.
That's why the
scale is balanced.
Now, let's think about
how we can represent this
symbolically.
So the first thing I
want you to think about
is, can we set up
an equation that
expresses that we have these
three things of mass x,
and that in total, their mass
is equal to the total mass
over here?
Can we express that
as an equation?
And I'll give you a
few seconds to do it.
Well, let's think about it.
Over here, we have three
things with mass x.
So their total
mass, we could write
as-- we could write their
total mass as x plus x plus x.
And over here, we have nine
things with mass of 1 kilogram.
I guess we could
write 1 plus 1 plus 1.
That's 3.
Plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1.
How many is that?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And actually, this is a
mathematical representation.
If we set it up as
an equation, it's
an algebraic representation.
It's not the simplest
possible way we can do it,
but it is a reasonable
way to do it.
If we want, we can say, well, if
I have an x plus another x plus
another x, I have three x's.
So I could rewrite this as 3x.
And 3x will be equal to?
Well, if I sum up all of
these 1's right over here-- 1
plus 1 plus 1.
We're doing that.
We have 9 of them, so
we get 3x is equal to 9.
And let me make sure I did that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So that's how we
would set it up.
And so the next question
is, what would we do?
What can we do mathematically?
Actually, to either
one of these equations,
but we'll focus on
this one right now.
What can we do
mathematically in order
to essentially solve for the x?
In order to figure out what
that mystery mass actually is?
And I'll give you another
second or two to think about it.
Well, when we did
it the last time
with just the scales
we said, OK, we've
got three of these x's here.
We want to have just one x here.
So we can say,
whatever this x is,
if the scale stays
balanced, it's
going to be the same as
whatever we have there.
There might be a temptation
to subtract two of the x's
maybe from this side,
but that won't help us.
And we can even see it
mathematically over here.
If we subtract two
x's from both sides,
on the left-hand side you're
going to have 3x minus 2x.
And on the right-hand
side, you're
going to have 9 minus 2x.
And you're just going to
be left with 3 of something
minus 2 something is
just 1 of something.
So you will just have an x there
if you get rid of two of them.
But on the right-hand side,
you're going to get 9 minus 2
x's.
So the x's still
didn't help you out.
You still have a mystery
mass on the right-hand side.
So that doesn't help.
So instead, what we say is--
and we did this the last time.
We said, well, what if we
took 1/3 of these things?
If we take 1/3 of these things
and take 1/3 of these things,
we should still get the
same mass on both sides
because the original
things had the same mass.
And the equivalent of
doing that mathematically
is to say, why don't we
multiply both sides by 1/3?
Or another way to say it is we
could divide both sides by 3.
Multiplying by 1/3 is the
same thing as dividing by 3.
So we're going to multiply
both sides by 1/3.
When you multiply both sides
by 1/3-- visually over here,
if you had three x's,
you multiply it by 1/3,
you're only going
to have one x left.
If you have nine of
these one-kilogram boxes,
you multiply it by 1/3, you're
only going to have three left.
And over here, you
can even visually--
if you divide by 3, which is
the same thing as multiplying
by 1/3, you divide by 3.
So you divide by 3.
You have an x is equal
to a 1 plus 1 plus 1.
An x is equal to 3.
Or you see here,
an x is equal to 3.
Over here you do the math.
1/3 times 3 is 1.
You're left with 1x.
So you're left with x
is equal to 9 times 1/3.
Or you could even view
it as 9 divided by 3,
which is equal to 3.